I'm fabrice saut lamy I'm
a pre-sales or customer engineer and
engineer at google cloud france
I have a particular color and
attached to the rite she and I
present to you my accomplices hello lionel
touati has therefore broken godmother
also generates with with fabricators me I do
in the tech world
so here is lionel will accompany us
on a demonstration of the power and
capacity of the bundle part of the
google cloud platform offer and because I
say it from linthal not from google and I am
in charge of the commercial relationship  and
marketing with google in is better
europe middle east africa
so we will present to you the
strategic partnership of intel and google
thank you so over the last 17
years
google has passed its majority for for
information so 98 times the birth
but over the  17 last years
google has built its infrastructure to
develop its skills it is its
know-how around the hosting of the
commissioning  e of the search that you
know well probably use a
lot but also gmail maps I
will not list all the services
that google implements but with three
main success criteria it is fast
high availability and resilient that is to
say that even  when
something very catastrophic happens for you
users, there will be no impact and
it is this know-how that
today allows google to meet the
needs of end customers with very high
volumes, we are talking about more  of a
billion users of google solutions
humor account but also of a
billion end users on
gcp google cloud platform solutions
which leads me to present to you google
four platforms as being
ultimately google's ability to
support you with  its
business expertise to drive innovation
is our positioning and that
's how we help companies
improve their level of service
through tools
ge india one of the strong components
of google's infrastructure is its
network over the years it has grown
and expanded it is a global network and
bergers is owned by google which is a
cable operator that generates traffic
40% of the internet bandwidth,
thanks to our little neighbors from youtube,
which generates a lot of traffic, but
as a customer and as a business, you
can benefit from this from this network,
it's global and you'll see it, lionel
will make a  demonstration that
shows you how easy it is
to connect regions I will come back
to the subject of data centers which
are on the other side of the planet in a
few hundred milliseconds we
manage to access the machines we
were about to start  extremely
quickly and all that is thanks to
this physical infrastructure that
google operates the little yellow dots
that you see on the slide represent
what are called the points of presence
between begs these are the  set of
places where you can connect
from your datacenter your offices to
the google network to have even
more capacity for these reasons the
blue dots are the cash points that
allow you as a user
whether it is business or consumers
to access services
so as you can see the
concept we have a more than
global presence and which continues to expand
due to the increasing consumption of
bandwidth in the gcp offer you
will see that there is a multitude of
services
we will concentrate a little later on
the part concluded but in the
computing offer there are several elements
the concept computer jean these are
virtual machines at very
competitive prices we will come back to this is
extremely efficient due to the
partnership with intel la  concept of
nginn containers so what you
may not know is that each
time you consume a
google service as well on google the
platef  orme that counts you die
you use a container you are
all container users if you
use google services and google has
deployed know-how and sleep
that about 2 3 years ago was
carried out in the world of  'open source under
the name of cobourne and s is therefore an
open source solution allowing
to orchestrate at the scale of the containers
which contain the services the
applications once again this is
offered to you as a service manager
within google cloud platform  and
allows you the agility necessary to
introduce development methods
called development under you will satisfy
your developers with continuous integration
satisfy your operations
with continuous deployment and thus be able to
have a virtuous devoxx process
reducing go to market and improving
your your services these presents and it
's part and it's based on the part
that we
finally pilot a last element which is
barely called jea  n but which is also the first
element that saw its birth within
google the platform to the first
services offered by the platform which
allows you without operation I have
developers of the code
I push this in peace jean and it's
the system that will do everything else
provisioning scaling auto feeling and
even stuff enough of the
medua b developer jargon testing of various
ning and that's all delivered to
you as a service you just have
to use it a bit like  a saaS mode and
it is based on google content so
we go from infrastructure mode where
you ultimately manage the
calf your resources enormously to breakage mode then
go where there are fewer and fewer aups
associated with operations a little focus  on
computer jean computer jean for google
its strengths are as follows
it is extremely quick and easy to
get started and I hope you will be
convinced after
lionel's demonstration it is something that is
easy to access  entirely à pays' and
everything is à pays on google cloud
platform you only pay for what you
use as in all claude but
with a particularity the
more you consume the less the
expensive unit price was explained during the
keynote but the more you  conceive you
keep your resources
and the more the associated discount increased up
to 30% which is a particularity
of the gcp offer we will come back to
virtual machines
today you can have
machines that go up to 624 giga of
ram and  96 vcpus know that this is only the
beginning
we have the capacity for this year
to deliver virtual
machines up to 4 gigabytes of ram and an
appropriate number of vcpus for
the operation of your solutions and in
particular  solutions which are
currently being certified
or certified on cvm where they are
nice na in memory database which requires
substantial resources for
large volumes
finally the one size of ascot fit hall
so what is  that means in
classic cloud users you
are forced to select a size
should m6 7e suit you it's perfect
you are in the best of worlds
you are optimized and then on the other hand in
use you can realize that
ben cvm lin  are not necessarily ideal
for your use case
we will see a little later how you
can solve this problem to be
financially optimized on the
consumption and the cost of your vm
finally security compliance so
everyone says yes it's super secure
etc.
at google we are extremely exposed
I don't think there is any need to
remind you and security is part of
the very DNA of any service that is created
on google there are 700 engineers who are
paid to try to crack all the
sr they put in place so we are very
vigilant about that and we can not
afford security breaches
for once we are extremely reactive
and everything is thought security at the base of
the creation  ation of services within the framework
of vm all flows in transit as they
say and you have you remain are encrypted in
other words when you put
data in a virtual disk associated
with machines
it is encrypted so if I resume at
high level
what you  have in the confiote part
we will start from the network the network and
global it is a network called sdr software
defined network which allows you to
create resources inside this
network
in regions the regions are
datacenter locations so the
closer to us today and at the end of lille
1 which are in belgium
about fifty kilometers from
lille and which makes it possible to accommodate several
zones the zone at zone b zone c these
zones are in fact  data center
which are interconnected to have
low network latency the advantage is
when when you have deployed your vm
which themselves have classic physical disk
or high performance or even
local is s  d even more efficient will
be hosted within a zone and you
will be able to have intra
zone communications forbidden to extremely
fast forgiveness with extremely
low latency this ecosystem the beginning
interacts with it first element
all creation or activation
generation the  management of these objects
is done by api or through the
web console or by a command line client
to be able to be an
automated manager compose from
automation tools claude formation
theraform is also such a great advertisement
and leader a whole an ecosystem again
once within google cloud
platform everything is country' and therefore you
can recover all the
elements create them from these api an
important element of the network
is ultimately the ability to see
google cloud platform as an
extension of  your own network
the dat ass the zones being
extensions of vaud datacenter or see
your new data center entirely  t
virtualized secure but which is seen
by your legacy systems or your employees
as the datacenter at the beginning and we
speak of interconnection or vpn vpn
being a rather logical connection which
is in christ the flow the
interconnect part is a physical connection
up to  at a point of peering the little
yellow balls that we had on the graph
just now finally you can
completely close this network
in your projects or authorize
flows to the internet depending on the
service you want to provide access
in  cream or purely internet access in the case
of e-commerce you will have dionne
take for the back office and then
internet access to render the pages
to your your customers I come back to the
personalized machines very often
when you start your vm you
will say but  I don't know in this
cloud how much ram
etc I need very precisely so you
will take a vm offered at a
cost that suits you and depending on  tion
of the returns of use you will be
able to finely tune the consumption
and you are not obliged to have so much
drama or attempt cpu ski term in
sur dives and m the cost delta is
not enormous on two thousand cores  or
twenty thousand cores as amadeus had specified
earlier we are starting to
have a real return on these investments
to be able to choose the size of cvm
finally in terms of cpu power
you also have the choice of the different
cpu technologies that you  are
proposed and we will return to the
advantages brought by sky like
through the presentation of pascal vm
préamp tible you may have heard
this dirty word during the presentations of the
kilo this morning it is a vm which is
identical to a vein  classic why
bear the name of anti bhl loan it's
because we may want to take it we can
tell you we need it we will take it back
only you had the right
to use it at 80% of the initial price
you had  ez cheaper than the initial price
so 20% which means that for some
computing workload or finally the fact
of withdrawing from the vm will just
increase your computing time but if
all goes well you may have
kept the vm for  throughout the duration
you will drop a lot of 80% on
cvm there suddenly it is extremely
appropriate for calculation on
giving it for hpc etc etc and it really has a
lot
of added value because in terms of
power you have  the mvm soul than the
classic vm startups lionel will give a
demonstration we are extremely
efficient very often in
cloud projects what I encounter is that
people do lift and shift identically
so we have the  same power it's true
that implemented dynamic resource
it takes a bit of work and
testing mail advantage is huge from a
tested point of view in total cost of
ownership and especially in the context of gc
pays you don't have  need  e making
reservation capacity planning
is extremely fast so we will
quickly bring you the resource
there is no huge latency of
several tens or fifteen
minutes to be able to have the resource
it is the story of a few  seconds we
will see and finally what you what
you benefit from is extremely
powerful I say them and I re-
emphasize the aspect the interface shows it exactly
very often on this on
many calls it is entirely to country' and
so we don't want to force you into a
mode of interaction with the platform
you can integrate these APIs into your
provisioning systems your
resource management or asset
management systems even to know what you
have provisioned and automated
recovery plans  of activity
finally a certain number of youth
what allows you to
avoid having a person at 3 o'clock in the morning
who comes and says hey
I have to strong that a vm because we
needs resources
another important differentiating
point and i'll stop there i have i'm
right in time is that when
you start a vm and it's a
differentiator gaulle what platform
it will never be turned off for
maintenance reasons so hot
google is forced to do the same
its waters of maintaining
operating conditions of its own servers
security patches os updates and
it's on the hypervisor so your vms
will be moved to  hot without breaking
service and it's a google know-how
which has been present for a long time and which
is unique on the public cloud
small points also which are
important when I interact with the
cloud if I have been doing it since my young
prem in  the framework in particular
of interactions with my services often
I am obliged to go through a bastion
or to open flows from my own
network and when I want to go very quickly
on the notion of provocative concept or two
things  - production but more
development testing innovation
well I can be blocked by my haiti
by different things within google
cloud you have access to a vm
called the cloud shell which is
provisioned on the fly when you
request it and  which allows you to interact
with all of your objects which
has all the api and sdk
installed as well as a guide makes a name
a certain number of tools which
allow you to interact and it is
available directly  in your
browser
so you can access it quite
easily the big added value
I use a lot so through
this presentation I have you I
focused on the computer jeans part
within google and through the
different sessions we have elements
more specific on
networking storage management big data
machine learning which is a big topic right
now and developer tools
I would never have had time
to cover everything on one this  session of 15
minutes but I hope that I have
given you enough in life to go and
look at what is happening in these in
these areas of expertise
because in the end we are convinced of this
we have all the tools necessary
to allow you to  have
efficient, innovative and
resilient workloads I'm handing over to
lionel to show you things in
action over about fifteen minutes
thank you
so I'm going to put a little bit
bigger is that in the direction of the
room you can see it's ok  ok great
so here it is the interface of the cloud
platform we will start very simple we
will create two virtual machines and its
virtual machines in fact we will
make one
in the us and one in europe so
here I am creating my first  virtual machine
so in saint ghislain in this case and
I'm going to call it gcp shoot eu
so I put a little a little
tool called times which will actually
allow me to calculate
the execution time  n of the order
and so here it is always a bit long
so even if it's fast it's
always a bit far when you do this at the
appointment so in parallel with that I
'm going to show you what's going on
on on  the console there on the console
that's bad that's it my bm is created it's
available and I'll be able to go
connect in ssh you'll show it after
that so here's the gemmi 19 seconds
to create the vm and so we're going to create
another vml  in the united states in a
region called him is a troll with us
so and in iowa and that's how I
showed you a little bit the
communication between the vm so there
you go so there are always these 19
seconds  don't expect much
but when we're in demo on a little
far from sorry for that so I'm
going to go back there so I'm going to do a
refresh the second gema vm that
appeared and suddenly I'm going to be able to
click on the button and c  that's what we
see here so I'm going to do it for the first
time  and I want to do it a second
time and there what happens
the platform in fact will take my
identity so in this case my login
cl touati at google.com check that I
have the right to access  its resources
create a temporary ssh key and push
this ssh key to my virtual machine
so it takes a little time but
the interest is that if tomorrow in fact we
don't leave this project for some reason
xyz suddenly in fact  I have more keys
available on the machines
I can take longer and therefore my
identity through the cloud platform
is also my identity in my
virtual machine and that from a security point of view
is enough is enough  quite
important
so once I'm
on these machines we go we go the ping
is so there we go the ping is then
I have a colleague who says it's the
bonaldi effect and oh yes it's me  that
usually happens it's faster so there are
actually two things that are important
the first  re is that a demo
never goes well unfortunately the second is that
you see I typed gcp us which is the
name of my virtual machine and there in
fact I have a dns integrated into the clotte
platform so I  I don't need to
manage that and it's one of the dynamic niners,
that is to say that each
time I create a new
virtual machine automatically it is
registered in the dns so it
simplifies life the other point and
c  was the purpose of the demo is to
show you in fact that I have a machine
so and in iowa is a machine that
in belgium seven thousand three hundred
kilometers as the crow flies two
distances well well I have  a ping 200
milliseconds so I'm not the
speed of light but at a speed
that is extremely fast and above all
it's extremely stable and that too
is very important especially when you
want to create resilient applications
because well here we can  rely
on a network that is very
efficient so the other thing  what I'm going
to show you is that there I created
machines, they're very small machines, we're going to see them here, they're
machines in fact with a single core and 4
gigas of ram, so giving in is really
the smallest machines in fact that are
available on the platform, on the
other hand, are dedicated curses and choirs
and suddenly I will still give
you a little test which is
in fact the download of an image of  a
debian image so it's an iso so it
's 35 gigabytes and there what's
interesting is that figure 23 megabytes
per second we have a network in fact
including when we access resources
that are at the  off the coast
platform which is extremely efficient and
we don't need to provision the
network dedicated to the ps this kind of thing
actually does that well directly with the
platform
hop here I am going to kill my machines
so the second demo that I  wanted
to show you this is the
multiple machine creation demo so the i  dice being
that well there we created two machines
it was it was funny but we can of
course in fact create machines
much faster and many and
many machines at the same time so
here we are going to use a shop called
l  now this group as its
name indicates in fact it is therefore a group
of virtual machines which will be
managed by google so basically we will
give it the characteristics of the
locations a number of machines etc
and it is the platform which  will manage that
so there in this case we will tell him I
want to create in fact a hundred
virtual machines and his
virtual machines I want to make them
available in the europe region where
is belgium which is itself composed
of three  zones a zone being
a data center and suddenly in fact there I
'm going to do I'm going to do that so that my
two little seconds to think and
soon I'm going to have my my machines
that are going to start
up so that's a mechanism of  security
that we have at google so there is a
small key in fact which allows us to
modify and which allows us to ensure
that we have the right people the right
people who are
who are accessing the platform so
here we are in fact  saw in a few
seconds
I think it took longer in fact
that I activate my key and that's what
other things but I have my hundreds
of vm that has been that has been created and that
allows me  in fact to deal with
mechanisms of what we call auto
skelling so platforms in fact that
they will need to grow
in an extremely important way in a
very short period of time
and that's it that will allow me to manage
all here and there I have 100 instances that
are available in the space of a year the
time it took to say it even a
little less than the other interest
is that these instances are straddling
party on three availability zones in
europe and so suddenly if ever in fact
for some reason xyz
here it is  I'm going to destroy up instances
automatically in fact the system has
detected that three instances are missing and
therefore suddenly go and recreate them so there for once
as part of the demo it
's not very interesting but if we
have applications that  are not very
efficient on which we are going to have
memory leaks this kind of thing we are going
to put in place in fact d el sheikh
so they will in fact validate the state of
the machine and if for one reason or
another the el  sheikh does not pass there
the system in fact will kill the
virtual machine have recreated another ex nihilo
and so that saves having to get
up at night because we have a server that
is planted and its excesses
and so I wanted to do  a third
a third of the words which is in
fact based on the principles of self-scanning
and therefore self-scanning with us in
fact is therefore this ability,
depending on a certain number
of events, to create machines to
respond  in charge
so there I  ust we went from 100 to 0
virtual machines in the space of two
seconds and therefore to a group of instances
in fact it will use several
several mechanics a car what is
their share in his suitcase and several
mechanics
the first c  is a moment this group
so what I showed you earlier
so this ability in fact to
manage a pool of virtual machines
together and to ensure its
performance after that will use a
moment this temple is therefore a moment  this
temple is what is it is the
definition of a non-instantiated virtual machine
so there in this case I have
a simple machine, a standard one
that will use debian and this
virtual machine will use a  what is
called a startup script this script in
fact it will be executed as soon as the
machine starts evala allow to
allow it to be configured
so here I am making a very simple example I
will install an apache and a ph p I
get some code and I  i my
machine which works and the last
point which is important is the
load balancing part and therefore the load balancers
so we call the globo loadbalancer
at home it is a network mechanism which
is not based on virtual instances
as with our
competitors
it's a network mechanism so what that
means is that we don't
need preheating
it's a mechanism capable of ski
up to a million requests per
second without  we need to call
google for us to run
scripts or whatever that's the
first advantage is the second
advantage is based on our network
is so this ip address the a35 tip
of 101 it's  available
globally and if we have applications
that are available for example in
the United States in Europe etc.
the users will be removed in
a completely transparent and
dynamic way to the zone closest
to them which will make it possible to reduce
in an e
the latency is extremely high so suddenly my little
application that I created I'm going to
put a bigger one because we do
n't see much what it does in fact
is that it calculates a Fibonacci sequence
it  is the example in php that I found
the easiest to consume cpu
it is not necessarily the smartest
but here it is and suddenly the principle
in fact of this application is that
it is a lot of cpu consumption
because in fact we're going to calculate
factorials etc. it's not a
database network or anything
it's really only cpu and suddenly what
we're going to do is we're going to launch a
tool called seats and so seat
what does it is quite stupid eh
it connects to the machine and then
sends them traffic it sends traffic to it
and so there obviously with a
single virtual machine the  system it is
more difficult to operate 1 because
well we use a heart and here
we go and so there we are going to put  e actually set up the
auto skelling mechanisms and therefore
set up the auto
skelling mechanisms it's quite simple we will go
to the group instance
and there we will give it
auto skelling parameters so we will  tell him auto
scale and auto which is not
based on the cpu and then you can auto skele
up to 100 virtual machines have of
course we are we are not obliged we can
we can put the number we want but
the idea is to try to put as
much as possible so the lotto steelers who
will do is that he will think
for a minute to try
to understand in fact what is the
problem we are trying  from calais we are
trying to answer
and above all how to answer it and so
after a minute what will happen
is who will in fact create a certain
number of virtual machines for me
here and he has already made the decision
he s  is said there the machine is
dying so it's useless I create
directly I pass  e to ten
instance automatically and this is in fact
where we see the interest of starting
the creation of fast machines, that is to
say that there in the space of a few
seconds lotto what time he
understood  that well I had a lot of
traffic and that my application with a
single machine with a single core
will never succeed and so suddenly he
immediately decides to increase the
number of machines and here I am  like
said I said but instances
running and the system will give me
so it continues to run greenhouse that there
it is still analyzing my
application
is what it is actually trying to
do is  finding the optimal cpu usage
for my application to
work as well as possible and therefore it
takes time because there are quite a few
risks behind which is being put
in place but suddenly you see in a
few seconds
I went from a  app that's
probably was dying
and v  here and to an application that will
hopefully come back to life no it's the effect of the
bulldogs and it's rowing a little so has
beds times there so there I'm
creating my virtual machines
we're the traffic is in the process  to come back
and so in a few seconds
normally my application will be
available and the other interest is that
when on the other hand I'm going to stop my
traffic here and there I'm going to automatically come back to
the car what is theirs will
understand that there he  no longer needs to
create vms and suddenly in fact it will
roll back and it will in fact kill
the vms as it goes to
avoid me paying vms for a
whole month when I need them so that
for a few seconds
the other interest is the management of
the availability zones there too we will be
able to manage it with that and
therefore automatically in fact we will
in fact create vms on several
availability zones so mr very  simple to have
extreme applications  resilient
ent since well here we are going to be able
to update them in a simple way and
last point which is interesting and
then I'm going to hand over
it's these rowling update mechanisms
and their triplex eurostar lines one
of the use cases  the most common on
a virtual machine is I need
to update the virtual machine
because I need to install
patches or whatever there we will be
able to do rolling
restarts
so we  going to be able to tell her this
virtual machine i want her to
use another temple is for example
more cpu or a different disk etc
and so the system will
transparently take in fact switch my
instance pool in fact from one  version
a to a version b and as with
containers if we ever need to
go back
we can do it with these systems there
so we have systems that are
both very resilient but also
know how to work well with d  are put into
production and agile methods as we
can see them
on a daily basis and so here are 35 thousand names
350 2000 45 78 thank you very much thank you
Lyonnais thank you very much
so it's true that on the appearance of
words 19 seconds or even thirty seconds
it's long when we're in front of you but
I can tell you that for having
met in Haiti where developers
who wait several weeks to
have their vm
we are still always ahead I
allow myself to introduce Pascal and and
seemed super important to talk to you
about this strategic partnership
with intel which is I think unique in the
world
on the cloud aspect is who and who will
be presented directly by intel I
ask you to welcome pascal thank you
welcome back so before moving on to the
slides g who who was there this morning at
who note from Sébastien Marotte in the
plenary room remember we
ultimately invited guests to take a trip back
in time to come back ten years ago in 2007
TV market  mobile phone
I suggest you go back a
little further at the beginning of the 2000s by
google starts with its
search engine and intel is already alongside
google
not many people know it but hey they
google is developing its server
farms six server farms  servers are powered
like today by xeon processors
and then we support them so the era
was not necessarily called zero like
today but hey we're there
alongside them 20th pro and other things
and then over  time this relationship
is tough we are also there by their
side to develop open
source software whether it is android
chromium and then closer to us
writes burn it is then on flo well we
could have gotten away with it  hold on there we could have
had this relationship
key technological partner in supplier and
supplier of processors we place the
order thank you goodbye but there is
something which happened
three years ago two three years
two things on both sides  another one
on the google side two years ago the
appointment of a person is called
times green key the boss of google
cloud today
one of the founders of vm ware who
arrived at google with her mentality her
culture vmware and kddi  if we want to be
among the greatest in terms
of cloud service provider we must have
a partnership approach
we must work hand in hand with the
partners to approach the
market together the company on the intel side
one thing happened  a little different of
course we were a company
built on pc and
server technology all around
and then it markets volumes and
two years ago we also
started a transformation to move towards a
company centered on the cloud and
the  internet of things with in the middle of
all that an interconnection in 5 days so
we have invested enormously in techno
Algiers know it's normal I have paper
on it ah I do it without slide so we
have developed enormously  ent these
5 g technologies it is not very apparent for
the moment that the first
marketings will happen in two or three years
but we think that it will play a
decisive role in the interconnection it is not
necessarily for the smartphone  or the
tablet but for all that is
connected city road connected
autonomous cars and so on there is
really this overall species giresse
with on the edge connected objects in
20 25 billion by 2020 according to the
research institutes  in water the cloud which
federates a little bit all this data
these steps have data and then between
the two the 5g
why I tell you this because there
is a given moment but google and
intel looked at each other are said but we are
finally  in the same inspiration we
are in a complementary way their
something similar is what
it gave in fact that's it and here it
works
our two diana so from a green at
google dyan bryant at intel who is a
little p  had the equivalent of the green dagger
in the sense that she is the boss of
the datacenter business unit what did
they decide they decided to
sign a partnership permit together a
strong partnership a
multi-year alliance around innovation
technological but also marketing and
commercial this is what I will try
to explain to you in the following minutes
and not just tell you
stories of alliances but also
explain to you how it can
benefit you so I quickly
go over it  because I just told you
about it
here is what happened in
practice we signed it in November
and very quickly we were in the
process of preparing our new generation
of xeon processors I was telling you about
it in more detail but generation  really
run revolutionary from a performance point of
view and immediately
google said we want it and we want it
before everyone is good we intel
don't want reserved one  processor for
justin customers of which we said we
offer everyone and the one who goes the
fastest wins in this case and and google,
that is to say that in three months he had
validated this new architecture 0
for their farm of  servers and as early as
February he was offering this new xeo we're
going to call it sky like without a
code name the full name is intel xeon what
processor bowls you understand that
's a little bit far to say in a
presentation are all I  going to say it
several times so we're going to say skydeck
and so google introduced it at the end of February
for information intel put this
processor on the market in July so
it was almost six months before we
launched the processor to offer it to
their customers  by saying come and try this
processor you will see the great
performance
good all that obviously with more
than a decade of collaboration between
us here we are talking about the sixth
generation 2 0 you have to know that
today
intel is taking legal action  sors tailor-made
for google so we are in
something very optimized yes just a
little note in passing so you
understand why the photo here
radzinski landes at intel the vice
president of cloud activities who
reports to ba tan bryant you saw
everything earlier  hour a side a
historical figure at google
the number 8 employee at google the
first employee on the cloud at google
a long long time ago he
is the father 1 he is the progenitor of the
datacenter at google pink bear knows it
himself-  even who introduced this processor
that was the equivalent of what you
have today in paris in san francisco
in the month of march
and so they were both on
stage for that's not someone
very  demonstrative for it's his first name
he's not very demonstrative like
sir and when they move to
announce something it's that for
him it's really important
so we'll try to explain to you
why it's important
here  this famous xeros sky like which
has several names
because it is a family of processors, in
this case the one used by google and
of the platinum type, you can see that it
offers you performance gains, so
two bases, we will say on average + 20%
on 1 see claude standard 6th workload
being workload said hpc high performance
computing intensive computing we can go up
to 48% 6th even cloning pc has been
optimized from the point of view of the code
with new instructions said had x
512 preceded qu torrio the instruction
512 bits for those who want to know
we can go up to 82% good
performance
we are really on the huge market in
general when we go from one generation
of processors to another at intel
honda legal perf of 5 10 15% better there
we are on something
substantial that's why I'm dwelling on it we
also have a gain on memory bandwidth
and that's very important you
'll understand why
so first of all yes c  is that we use
all that goes in all kinds of
fields because good technology
these ladies we have to be
able to apply it
so intensive computing we will
find it well in the weather
forecast in the calculation of
financial risk time
self-taught analytics of machine
learning in defense in
simulation in the ceao in
in energy in people looking for
oil gas and others in the calculation
of the genome
so there are quite a few fields
of application we will find that at
level of google cloud platform in
several types of products
or instances so here today we are
talking to you about gsee
thanks to the superb and words of lionel
and the bonaldi law that goes with it
we find that as dangerous as it
means  what does it mean that when
you go to configure your
computer instances I have it is that you have an
option to choose skydeck I want more
performance I choose this case it is the
same on gk them which is the instant  this number of
containers at google
and then so many products managed plus
this is happening we will also find this in
data flow at the date analytics level we have
the sky like option for those who do
rendering for those who like
films images buildings  the animations
on the zing platform one can
select style is that one can also
use what alleges to do some and
undermine his pay since it's
certified can go up
to four ram land configurations
if you need  four pitches
of ram you can also associate it with it and
artificial intelligence software hit your forehead then a
sequel which I
'll tell you about later here's on the console well here
it's very simple it's like another
gsee instance
we're leaving for m small novelty we can
now go up to 96 cores 96
vcpu before the limitation it was 64 with
sky like we can go up to 96 why
because there are more physical hearts
in sky like the gen  previous era
it was a processor with 22
physical cores extracted as soon as you go up to 28
and then in ram as I said you
can go up to configurations
of four fields on a vm up to
624 giga so it increases
it wants  say what for customers you
have a small sample of
customer testimonials in different fields
so that's sedan biomedical in
gaming biotech in weather forecasting
it's people who tested
skyline at google so we're not talking
about testing in a
anber metal lab we are really at google
on the cloud with
real life applications and we have all come out of two
performance gains depending on what we are
looking for just to clarify I was
talking to you about platinum segré it is
not  all alone in the family of
bronze silver gold a bit like the olympic games
just to tell you that this family
of intel xeon this case the khaleq processor bowls
is in fact the evolution of two
families  for those who are a little bit
connoisseur of xeon processors in the
past there was a family the five of them
left family manage mid-range a
bit the all-purpose processor in quad bi-
socket and then there family e7 plus
michel critique high-end hall  with
all kinds of big one ryoke config
early on we just took these two
families we put them together and we gave
birth to this range of xeros that it
is good hence the name what they
want and you imagine but hey the
hierarchy is starting to tan finished
platinum just to tell you that in
the context of google cloud it's
platinum that is used here I'm going to
go a little faster on
that because we won't necessarily have time to
see everything
saas software optimization is an
important step because I told you
that the process without itself brings
performance and they lose even
more years if the software is optimized
so there we have two approaches we have an
eco sy approach  system
so we work with a whole host
of software publisher wenders
in this case we only cover a little
more than 7000 in the business world
it's something that you haven't done
for more than 25  years later since
the birth of windows on the pc here are
my then we continued in open
source and in all kinds of
architecture and then we also have the
case where the application is
developed at home by the customer by
his  developers
and in this case we have a suite
of tools called parallel studio
xx e for friends that allows you to
re-compile your application with the
right libraries
our different
languages optimize with a tool calle
vtune therefore to resume your code
and then to see exactly step by
step where the code is potentially
slowed down and how to improve it
see also to make parallelization
with yet another suite of tools
so either we address the editor of
software either if it's homemade
we provide the tools that
optimize the code for this latest
generation of processor this is my
last slide admit it's there I
invite you to test sky like because good
it's  fine to take my word for it
but the best thing is to test
it we offer you several things google
and intel together to make advanced teachers at
this time with
funding through google partners we
also offer you to test two beautiful
your social application is that we will
say sorry sky like with the
generation before called brad wall to
do duke side by side
and then to measure the
performance gains are at sky like credits
on gc pays to do that  and then
in general we encourage you to
work only with google partners
who are also equipped
and trained for this technology,
thank you thank you